social networks baby who here does
social network analysis raise your hand
yeah very nice
so did you know that who's the lead
guitarist of Queen by the way Brian May
did you know that he has a PhD in
astrophysics so it turns out when he was
in his last year of his ph.d program he
was in the queen' band and then queen
happened and he's like okay I guess I'm
doing the Korean thing now Queen happens
and then many years later in 2007 he
went back and finished his dissertation
so he's been published in many academic
journals in addition he does a lot of
books of the big bang for the laymen and
it's super fun to read so the moral of
the story is in all of us who's a
creative person and then there's the
math nerd person you should combine them
both it is your duty to combine both
sides and the reason one reason why I
love social network analysis is it's so
clear why those two sides come together
in data analytics so there's the art
side because just really fun visuals and
there's the analytics side in the
statistics which I'll show you so these
are two of my passions so today I'm
going to talk about social network
analysis specifically in the case of the
organization where I work which is the
inter-american Development Bank and I
make us what's called the citation
Network and I want you to think about
how you could apply this at your company
so first of all I'm really an art nerd
and recently we did this really fun
pumpkin carving and then in my house and
of course I had to make car I also may
or may not have made our cupcakes at one
point which you can see in the corner
here and so I'm a super our geek and I
love this conference by the way so
overview first of all I'm going to talk
about what is a citation network and the
how do you how do you actually build one
yourself we'll look at the example I use
from the inter-american Development Bank
we'll think about how do you analyze a
graph and then we'll do a wrap-up so
first of all what is a citation Network
basically it's a type of social network
analysis so what is that it basically
means you have a set of actors and
you're mapping the interrelationships
across over those different actors so
this is a classic example where you have
people and then you could see these
little arrows across the different
people that might represent friendship
groups or they could be communications
they could be some sort of management
structure at an organization but you can
also replace those actors instead of
people you could do something like
documents or papers and a citation
network often is doing just that you
basically take a set of people you can
take the AquaDuck you can take academic
papers and map the different citations
across those it also doesn't have to be
academic papers it could be something
else so here's an example let's look at
the citation patterns across different
academic disciplines think about what
you think is the discipline that gets
the most citations that has the largest
volumes of citations psychology other
ideas medicine other ideas biology ok so
here's the answer this is a study done
in 2008 and it turns out that the
largest nodes I don't know if you can
see this but medicine and molecular
biology have the largest volume of
citations this is a study done on over
6,000 journals connected by over 6
million citations and then grouped
grouping them by discipline so you can
see that for example there are arrows
between different disciplines which
might suggest that there's a lot of
cross-pollination across those fields so
obviously medicine and molecular and
cell biology are very related so they
cite each other a lot but economic
doesn't look like it has very many
citations with medicine it also looks
like economics this has a small volume
of citations relative to these fields or
physics or neuroscience so you can also
think about well where are there
opportunities for different types of
research so why are we not combining
more I don't know probability and
statistics with geosciences for example
so you can kind of see both the the
interactions in the inter relationships
as well as the gaps in knowledge here's
another example so in this data set in
this study from 2017 you have political
tweets on three different politically
hot topics gun control same-sex marriage
and climate change and then the nodes
are colored by mean ideology so liberal
or conservative so a node is a user and
a link represents of retweet to another
user so what can you get from this graph
well it looks like there's a lot of
clustering within users of the same
ideological community so it looks like
people are sharing information with
those who have like views and there
aren't as many users who are sort of
bridging the gap between these two
different ideologies so again citation
networks can apply to many different
things it doesn't have to be just
academic papers so why are citation
networks useful one they map the
influence of ideas you can measure it
the impact in the spread of knowledge
two they identify key actors who is
cited the most this is often what people
first think of when they think of who's
important in a network but you can also
think about who does the citing it's
just as important that academics are
anyone in a particular network actually
is the connector between different nodes
because if there's no one who's bridging
the gap then there really isn't a
network at all three they reveal
clusters as well as gaps in knowledge so
how do you actually build a citation
network network information can be rivet
written in two equivalent ways one is
called an adjacency matrix so this is a
very basic
sample of a graph so basically you have
these five nodes and four of them are
connected and the fifth is sort of
floating by itself it's called an
undirected graph because there's no
arrows you just have a link or there's
no link and to record this information
you have a symmetric matrix here it's
always a square matrix so you have five
rows 5 columns because there are five
nodes in the network you put a 1 if
there's a link between the two nodes and
a zero if there's not notice for example
that 2 is connected to 1 so a 2 is a 1
with column a 1 likewise a 1 is a 1 with
column a 2 so this is a symmetric matrix
if you have a directed graph then that
just means you have arrows so in this
case two sites 1 for example but one is
not citing 2 and in this case you'd no
longer have symmetry and the matrix so
I've just highlighted in red the places
where it was a one before and now it's a
zero because in this case b1 is no
longer citing b2 so it's a zero so
that's one way to store your network
data what do you think is going to be a
problem with this format sparsity yes
what if you have a really big network of
say a thousand nodes you're gonna have a
thousand columns and a thousand rows and
a lot of those entries are going to be
zeros what's the point of holding in
your memory all the zeros it's going to
be eventually really hard to manipulate
and it's going to slow your machine down
so there's another way which is called
an edge list and basically that just
deletes all that zero information and
condenses your your data down into two
different columns from and to so in
practice do this don't do the other way
unless you want a really simple example
and you just want to see what it looks
like because once you enter your data
like this your whatever our package
you're working with can easily translate
it into a a Jason C matrix if you want
to see it so let's say you're working
with documents like is such as the case
I'm going to show you in my case I was
working with PDF documents and say
you're
looking for citations of a particular
document number so in this case the
document number I'm looking for is this
AR - thingy
then for character pattern recognition
use regular expressions such an
innocuous sounding word has anyone ever
used regular expressions here how many
people love them how many people hate
them how many people are like it depends
on the task yeah okay so this is usually
hit or miss in this case it worked
beautifully and brilliantly and I'll
show you an example the R package to use
is string r do not try to use base R for
this I did the whole thing in base are I
think a man are purest and I'm going to
use only base R for this and bad idea
bad so string are makes this so much
easier thank you to the tiny verse so
here's an example let's see if text that
is the project's AR - L 1281 and AR - LD
1302 were approved in 2018 our task we
want to search for the project numbers
so picture this is one big huge long 50
page PDF document and I just want to
pick out those particular citations
right and so here's the regular
expression you can have a look they're
not that hard to pick up the simpler the
better if they start to get really
complicated then maybe you want to try
something not a regular something other
than a regular expression but there's
lots of tutorials online and I think
they start to become kind of like a fun
word puzzle so you can have you have the
text like this and then you just use the
string our function which is string
extract all and then voila you get the
numbers out so imagine having a 50 page
document and that's how easy it is to
get these little citations so review why
you string are packaged well here's a
fun crossword for you and all of the
answers are string R so for example for
example it is built it is part of the
tidy verse universe it has its own
handy-dandy cheat sheet from our studio
which you can just google and find
it's much better than besar all kinds of
reasons so remember to use string r for
regular expressions so here's my
specific example from the inter-american
Development Bank the mission is to
reduce poverty and inequality in Latin
America and the Caribbean through
financial and technical support the bank
has had over 2,000 loans to sovereign
governments in the past ten years
roughly 200 billion dollars each of
these loans is considered a project and
each of these has its own document so
it's basically a 50 page document it
explains the why what how come how are
we going to do this of the project so
what is this loan citation network it is
a directed Network it is built from the
loan proposals over the past 10 years
each node represents a loan proposal or
a project and the links represent
citations to another project so you you
just build it in the exact same way I
said you make a loop through all these
different PDF documents and you pull out
the character patterns using regular
expressions and you format them in an
edge list it's that simple so an example
would be like this is a this is a
project approved recently and has you
know this particular paragraph and it
has in blue that's the citation of a
project and so what's the purpose of
this text well it's basically showing us
past accomplishments of the bank in that
particular sector it shows us a related
project and it shows the spread of ideas
so this is why it could be useful to the
organization so you go through this
algorithm and or this this code which
isn't that long it's only like you know
three or four hundred lines and you
produce an edge list and then you make a
beautiful graph I prefer Getty for the
graphing itself are such as the package
I graph they also make graphs but you
can do a lot of really cool stuff with
Jeffie and it's also free so this is an
example of how the graph is actually
made in Guffey the graph format itself
is a non-trivial thing basically you
all your points out in in the in the
program and they're just a random blob
but you can select a different type of
visualization in this case it's a force
Atlas algorithm basically what that does
is it clusters nodes together that have
a lot of common citations so and then it
spreads nodes a far away from each other
if they don't share a lot of common
citations so it's basically trying to
give us a visual of what are all these
clusters and then of course you can
color it by different things right now
it's colored by country but you can also
color it by say economic sector and
voila it's a different color you can
filter you could change the node size
here the node size is relative to the
size of the loan and dollars so it's a
really fun tool to use as a visual aid
so how do you analyze the graph I would
say there are three steps one is
visually so you make a visual like in
Getty if it's a really big graph I would
recommend guffy you can look for
clusters you can look for isolates you
can filter by different traits for
example in the IDB you could filter by
country or filter by department and to
quantitatively so one very common way of
looking at a graph is thinking about
what are the central nodes and there are
basically a bunch of formulas for
calculating what's the importance of
different nodes in the network for
example in the case of a citation
network you might look at well who's
doing the most citing who's being cited
the most and then there's all these
other types of centrality measures that
once you get into social network
analysis you can learn more about all of
these are available in I graph or the
stat net packages tidy graph was also
developed in 2017 and I believe it's
more of a wrapper around I graph three
you can model the network statistically
and I'll give you an example of that as
well so visually and our case we can
color by country which is what I showed
you before or you can then see and
compare the graph if it's colored by
economics
so when we say economic sector we mean
the education health transport some sort
of aspect of economic development so the
first thing you can kind of notice here
is that it looks visually like the
clusters are corresponding to the
country more than they correspond to
economic sector so it kind of looks like
there's a blue blob over here which I
believe is Brazil and then there is
green over here so all the colors seem
to kind of be overlapping with the
clusters whereas in the case of economic
sector it doesn't look like the the
clusters are correlated very much with
the colors so that leads to one possible
result which is maybe the clusters maybe
the citations happen more at the country
level rather than at the economic sector
level so that's a hypothesis we can test
with a model mathematically as I
mentioned you can look at the most
relevant loans in the network for
example by country it turns out at the
IDB that Haiti has the most cited loans
although Haiti has a smaller portion of
the total number of loans so Haiti's
loans I think around four or five
percent of total approvals but in fact
they're they're getting a lot of
traction they're getting a lot of the
ideas that are happening in Haiti as far
as economic development are being spread
across the organization Brazil on the
other hand being the biggest country
does a lot of citing but the loans
aren't is relevant to a lot of the
others in the network as far as economic
sector climate change trade and
investment energy and transport are
getting a lot of attention so even think
about this at your organization and
think well is it what are some of the
different units in my company that I can
sort of analyze is it apartment level is
it a project is it a team composition
you can start to think about the
different units you can analyze and see
how relevant they are in the network and
finally you can model the the network so
in this case we had a hypothesis which
was shared country increases the
probability of a citation between
projects so if I have two arbitrary
loans in Argentina those loans have
higher probability of sighting each
other than a loan that's Argentina and
Brazil so you would model this
statistically by asking what is the
probability of a link between two
arbitrary look notes the outcome is one
there's a link or zero there's no link
what kind of models this remind you of
I'm sorry like a logistic regression
right except there is interdependence
across the nodes so that messes up the
logistic regression and then you know
that it's like a really nasty time
series or geospatial model where you
have to model all this interdependence
across all the units and to avoid that
whole problem you do mark Monte Carlo
Markov chain and this model does just
that it's called exponential random
graph model it was developed by the stat
net team at the University of Washington
and they're always giving workshops
about this all over the world basically
so there's a lot of good literature on
this model and the package at R is
called ogum so here are the results
sorry to show you numbers basically you
can't include too many covariance
because the the MCMC doesn't like too
many so it's very delicate and it takes
a long time to run but just focus for a
second on the final two so we can see
that with if two nodes have the same
country then there's a positive effect
on the probability of a link and it's
significant in the same way if two
countries have the same division or the
same economic sector then again there's
a positive impact on the probability of
a link but you can see the the country
the shared country effect is stronger
than the shared division effect so you
interpret it in the same way as a
logistic regression you can calculate
the probabilities like so and then you
can compare the probabilities and it
turns out it's four point around four
four times more likely that countries
with the same that projects were the
same country share a link than project
with the same division why
this be interesting to an organization
like the IDB because it's showing you
that maybe there's country level silos
of information where projects within the
same country are really being the ideas
are being shared very frequently but
when there's a sector across countries
you're not really sharing that
information so as a wrap-up think about
how you can create a citation network at
your company you could do so through
emails through documents maybe there's
some sort of project level information
you can use
there's also team composition level if
you need to use pattern a character
pattern recognition use regular
expressions
what's the our package string are and
finally analyze the network with our
using eye graph and stat net visualize
with geppi and then you can test
hypotheses with statistical models such
as an urban thank you very much
[Applause]